en théorie le double est toujours
l'épreuve la plus conviviale d'un
tournoi et surtout le double mixte mais
ça c'est seulement en théorie Magalie et
Laurent en couple dans la vie ont vite
séparé les raquettes sur le terrain
ouais mais parce que des fois tu as des
histoires de couple qui ressort tout ça
sur le terrain c'est pas bon mieux vaut
ne pas avoir d'histoire de couple sur le
terrain quoi voilà c'est ça bah tu sais
pas ce qui s'est passé la veille voilà
qui sa qui a pas fait la vaisselle ou
des choses comme ça quoi de l'autre côté
du filet Jean-Christophe et maris en
couple également jouent ensemble depuis
2 ans et demi leur secret ce qui se
passe sur le terrain reste au bord du
filet je pense qu'il y a plein de choses
on se connaît bien mais après on se dit
aussi plus facilement les reproches donc
c'est voilà c'est ça le souci c'est
qu'il faut jongler à ce niveau-là voilà
faut dire les choses avec
diplomatie la réussite du double mix
passe donc par la diplomatie et surtout
une excellente stratégie la femme joue
le plus souvent à coup d'amorti l'homme
couvre le fond du terrain malgré leur
entente avec une victoire et une défaite
Mar et Jean-Christophe ne verront pas le
tableau finale de leur côté magie et
Laurent attendent de séchanger quelques
match en finale con de
Fabl pas du tout je sais que j'ai gagné
la finale dans
R